[Music]
good evening and welcome to lorry prints
live tonight subject the growing drug
epidemic in cities across the nation
drug use is up and crime is on the rise
should the government step in on the
growing war on drugs or is it a hands-on
approach that is the only solution in
this impossible dilemma I am joined here
today by clinical psychologist and
Harvard University professor Morales
Raja good to be back glory and with us
via satellite phone are two concerned
citizens who are doing their best to
raise awareness of the issue and mr.
Hatter and a mr. haire mr. Hatter how
are you this evening
wonderful Lloyd yes now mr. Henner am I
to assume that you are for the
legalization of marijuana well yeah and
what about PCP yes
crack cocaine yeah hope you yeah
methamphetamines oh my goodness yes oh
and don't forget the acid Laurie oh yes
yes oh definitely acid and of ecstasy
mescaline oh and what's that green BB
booze that makes you see things bigoted
friends absent kiff yes I just love
Epson you know that's legal now in this
country Oh Chuck sweet it's gone what
with a good guy well that sounds like a
very extensive list is there anything on
there you might have left out well
there's that hookah the blue caterpillar
smokes in that thing anyway I don't know
but I want something getting back to the
subject at hand
and this is a very touchy issue with
very touchy points of view a professor
Roger what's your take on this well I'm
appalled oh my goodness legalizing these
hazardous narcotics would be criminally
irresponsible and a gateway to rising
crime Oh lighten up seriously you need
to stop yapping and get hooked up with a
J I'm sorry I get high on life well you
certainly look at not what it's very
simple it's the parents responsibility
to take care of these matters so their
children don't plant the drugs in the
place that's right since the dawn of
time mankind has attempted to control
that which it didn't understand but with
every tightening of the grip comes
another lost soul slipped through the
fingers if we spend more time in the
home and less time in the offices of
some soulless bureaucracy then we'd have
less children slipping through
that's instead of turning to connect
well said but you know sometimes you
could be quite insightful well you know
what they say yeah today gone tomorrow
I've lost all respect for you oh yeah
well I've done a little research in your
late-night shenanigans and I've
discovered a laundry list of criminal
negligence yes we've all heard the
reports
thunderous all-night rave center around
the consumption of pastries and
fermented leaf beverage but God's sake
it's a harmless tea party well one
insider we will simply refer to her as
mrs. a had this to say what these to
call tea parties are nothing more than
backyard drug fueled inner species
orgies were underage drinking and
smoking go hand-in-hand
amid psychedelic acid tripping and
improper use of the condiment mustard
mustard don't let us be silly it wasn't
that wait wait I'm not finished and all
delivered in a shadowy haze of steam and
smoke that would make Cheech and Chong
pass out from overload now you may
respond that little apron wearing
Halloween is one to talk she said she
was sent to us by a disappearing talking
cat for crying out loud
Mikey you have a white rabbit what a
crazy proverbial load Laurie you to deny
any of the other charges disorderly
conduct serving a legal substance to a
minor we thought she was 21
numerous health code violations illegal
fireworks improperly set off from a cake
delivery system that was a bad email but
they excuse me but what is this very
Merry unbirthday that you speak of well
you see Laurie
everybody gets just one birthday so that
would technically mean that today is my
um birthday - it is what a small world
it is well in that case
oh no Laurie this is how they work
they're luring you in with the promise
of cake
yes yes I apologize I think it'll side
tractor there um why don't we go to the
phones and take a few calls hello caller
you are on the air uh yeah hi I have a
friend I know his name is mr. rabbit I'd
like to ask these two clowns about their
petty thievery or how about you know
practicing watch repair without a
license that watch was two days slow do
you have a license oh they did go to the
Rhine for two yeah yeah I think you guys
run something already
get rid of it losers my actually the
caller does bring up a very good point
how about a mr. Hatter what is in your
tea what are you implying that he is
made only with the finest of medicinal
and does that explain these PETA reports
about rampant animal abuse such as
sedating small mice by suffocating them
with globs of raspberry jelly okay so we
want the little Gaga while on the
Colombian cocoa tea but it's not like we
started our own Michael Vick dogfighting
ring no really that's not a bad idea I
totally agree give him a call
speaking of calls we have another caller
on the line hello caller you are on the
air hello Laurie
and glad to see you feel about nicely
mr. Joker I thought I had a restraining
order against you well technically I am
more than 50 feet away from you right
now all right what do you want I just
want to offer my take on the issue I did
that a cry no but everything else you've
done is Laurie
that hurts hey leave the clown alone he
just wants to voice his opinion thank
you a turd isn't this Laurie guy just
impossible quite impossible well my
thought is if people didn't want to do
drugs they wouldn't keep doing them it's
simple uh supply and demand
Laurie give the people what they want I
mean I hole here in all honesty can say
that they haven't done drugs once in
their life well I haven't neither have I
because you're not yes
quit but knock hey I am NOT Oh
where did you dig these guys up they are
a delight you know you should have these
guys are more often I think that would
be extraordinarily danger
do you guys do parties way through tea
parties good Casa I know someone very
special as a very merry unbirthday today
it's me yes it is well in that case well
I'd hate to interrupt your illness we do
have another caller on the line hello
caller you are on the air Rajesh do you
just religiously watch this show what
gives you the right to lecture us on
America's vast and overreaching drug
policy hey who's the clown and the
choker no I mean the other clown but one
of the best he's mister man and he's a
very very obnoxious caller I'm sorry
that was harsh I'll say yeah you want to
talk about it I'm sorry it's just it's
my own birthday today and nobody seems
to have noticed nobody is blowing out
any candles here you are such an ox got
a point there or you are a bit of a narc
I am NOT a knock knock knock knock knock
knock-knock-knock
I don't get it Professor Roger your
thoughts you are a bit of an art glory I
mean about the issue oh I don't know
this interview is over
thank you all for wasting my time oh
shut up Laurie I break explosives
underneath your seat if the show goes
off so do you well welcome to the 24
hour Laurie Prince marathon 24 hours
well you're gonna need music I'm on my
way
[Music]
I'm stuck in traffic
just hang tight don't be there in a few
hours I really need a pencil in order
for this trick to work